so here's a fun story michelle fiskus
was one of the top vaccine officials
here in tennessee she was fired
justifiably after distributing a memo
encouraging medical professionals to
vaccinate children
uh without their parents consent or
excuse me let me clarify
rather she uh she shared information
about how they could do that not that
she was suggesting it
all she was saying she she distributed
the memo
saying hey
i'm just saying you could vaccinate kids
without their parents look outside i'm
not encouraging you but
by the way here's the law and by the way
you could do that
hint wink wink
and in the middle of that backlash
um because this
this creep
was trying to supersede the authority of
parents
encouraging people to inject these
substances into kids without parents
even knowing in the middle of that
backlash before leaving her position she
claimed to have received a dog muzzle in
the mail as a threat of some kind from
presumably an anti-vaxxer probably a
trump trump supporter one of those
dangerous people you know here she is on
cnn this was a few weeks ago talking
about this uh terrible threat that she
received let's watch this
i i understand so just last week before
you were fired you received a disturbing
amazon package at your office
what what was in it and what did you
think when you received it
hi anderson thank you so much for having
me um yes the the week before i was um
terminated from the department of health
i received a package that contained a
dog muzzle
and
at first i thought that was a joke and
contacted a few friends and then when no
one claimed it realized that that was
something that was sent to me as some
kind of a message i suppose i understand
i think it was your husband who said or
you said something to your husband that
he recounted what was it you said
i said
that that they obviously didn't know me
because they sent me a size three which
is for beagles and i'm obviously a pit
bull which requires a size six
really clever
she's a pit bull all right
um question
again not being an expert on dogs are
pit bulls known for lying are they are
they a particularly deceptive breed of
dog maybe they are
because if so she's a pit bull because
as it turns out this was all shockingly
a lie now we have this from the daily
wire it says an investigation revealed
the muzzle was actually purchased on
fiskus's own credit card
though she still denies that she sent
the muzzle to herself as some sort of
hate hoax according to axios an
investigation from the tennessee
department of safety and homeland
security revealed that the amazon
package containing the dog muzzle was
traced back to a credit card in fiskus's
name
so no problem here it's a former
government official in charge of the
vaccines in the state
mailing a dog muzzle to herself
and so stupid
here's the thing that
where you want to say
it's almost hard to believe you almost
want to give her the benefit of the
doubt because you say would she really
be so dumb
as to perpetrate this hoax
in the first place but then to put it on
her own credit card
how stupid do you have to be
like why wouldn't you go at least if
you're gonna do this
go to a petsmart or something buy the
thing in cash
and then mail it to yourself at a you
know a mailbox somewhere in a shopping
center
a little bit harder to trace if you're
gonna do this whole thing then i mean
really go for it
instead she just went on amazon with her
own credit card sent it to herself
knowing it would be investigated and
they could easily obtain this
information
so you want to give it give her the
benefit out but of course you can't
because
um
these hate hope hoaxers as we have
learned time and time again really are
this stupid or maybe not so stupid at
all maybe she realized
that it didn't matter whether it was
true or not
all that matters is the initial headline
as we have also learned time and time
again with these hoaxes
all you got to do is get the get the
initial headline
you become a victim you get all that
attention
which you can profit off of and
capitalize on
if
a few weeks later or even a few days
later if it turns out the whole thing
was made up no it's
all of the people who are willing to
accept you as a martyr they don't care
the truth doesn't mean anything to them
so it might not be so stupid after all
she realizes that the people this is
meant to appeal to for them the truth is
totally irrelevant so
who cares
and that's exactly how it has uh has
turned out
um and she's still denying it she say i
didn't set it to myself i guess the the
person who sent the dog muzzle first
stole her credit card
maybe stole it from her purse
bought the dog muzzle mail to her and
then snuck into her house the middle
night and put the put the credit card
back in her purse you never know could
have happened
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content